you know it would be good to play Oh
Cuba Gooding jr. crush you thank you
that's why I think would play oh I feel
like me Roy Wood jr. and Craig Robinson
can all play each other
people always think I'm one of the
Impractical Jokers and I'm like no no no
I took the bus here what's up everybody
welcome to stupid questions I'm Christy
Stefano it's stand up month baby 2019
starting off with stand-up month I'm
excited I'm in a tux
I got Ron Funches his specials airing
it's called giggle v and it's hilarious
it's gonna do more than giggle yeah you
are probably go far that's it if you
were an action figure what would you
come with oh I will probably have like a
huggable action move I'm gonna hug you
and then it would probably come with
like a bong and then like skittles and
some Magnum condoms
we usually what we're found in my
pockets on a random day you got that big
dick energy like Pete Davidson here's a
question I designed just for you if you
were stuck in a video game universe
mm-hmm what universe would it be right
away I think about Mario because that
just seems far but I'm so very late
there's a lot of pipes you gotta go
through there's a lot a lot of enemies
sounds like you're living off a diet of
just mushrooms right and fire flowers
which you know it's a formative ly
healthy but yeah but it's like I like a
little meat in there okay so I think I
want to live in the Tecmo dead or alive
volleyball universe which is just a
bunch of women fighters that put instead
a fight and they're playing volleyball
in bikinis and I take pictures I don't
mean it the games creepy but I guess in
this universe I'm okay you do whatever
you want
Wow great yeah I'm not gonna go to a
violent area I did not expect to get to
volleyball that's a hot sport less
thighs in any sport absolutely thighs
[Music]
here's no stupid question if you were a
ghost who would you haunt my ex-wife I
don't wanna say that yeah bye oh it
definitely ha
she'll get it yeah she and she knows why
what about if he died a hundred years
ago a hundred years ago I guess I would
want my uncle Johnny well he's dead too
so I guess we'd just be haunting each
other do you believe in ghosts I believe
in I believe in whatever is more fun
right who I want something fried or
saute saute that sounds more fun yeah
you know and the ghosts and spirits
exist or do they not sounds more fun if
they do to me yeah why not
it's a good easy life all right thanks
for doing super questions thank you I'm
always a super questions you get a
stupid gift okay that's what it is so I
think you know you're big in a wrestling
bang what do you think of that you like
that yeah actually no yeah I got too big
of a head but it'll fit your head oh it
is tight I see what your problem was
before I'm glad to get on giggle fat man
just been great thank you I can't really
see you but I'm hope I'm looking in your
general direction
you